[Musique]
il y a un an les troupes russes
traversaient la frontière pour envahir
l'Ukraine depuis des millions
d'Ukrainiens se sont réfugiés un peu
partout dans le monde des centaines de
milliers d'autres ont pris les armes
pour défendre leur patrie des milliers
sont morts des civils des soldats
victimes des attaques russes la Russie
espérait une guerre éclair un an plus
tard le drapeau jaune et bleu flottent
toujours sur Kiev c'est là que je
retrouve Larissa galazza c'est
l'ambassadrice du Canada à Kiev un
Canada merci d'être avec nous bon
dimanche Merci à VOUS Daniel on s'est
parlé vous et moi au mois de mai au
moment où vous
réintégriez l'ambassade les quartiers
Canadiens à Kiev comment comment va la
vie à Kiev depuis comment et qu'est-ce
qu'elle est la différence entre le début
du conflit maintenant
ici et Kiev la vie quotidienne retour au
normal mais
chaque jour tous les jours il y a des
sirènes et et
la vie est souvent bouleversée
ailleurs dans le pays c'est beaucoup et
la guerre continue il y a des
bombardements tous les jours et et la
souffrance
la souffrance continue donc
ici et qui Ève nous trouvons dans dans
sécurité mais ailleurs c'est très très
difficile
un an plus tard
le moral est
fort ils sont fortement déterminés
ils sont très reconnaissantes de l'appui
et qu'il fournira leur partenaire il
me remercie tous les jours que nous
sommes présentes ici en Ukraine et ils
sont déterminés aller à la victoire
pensez-vous madame galazza pensez-vous
l'année dernière qu'un an plus tard on
serait toujours dans ce conflit
je me souviens très bien du moment
il y a un ange pour jour que nous avons
réalisé nous avions réalisé que nous pas
rester ici
à ce moment-là je t'ai convaincue que je
reviendrai mais ce que mais j'avais peur
de la question je ne savais tout
simplement pas
qu'est-ce que nous allons trouver ici en
Ukraine aujourd'hui nous nous sommes ici
avec un peuple déterminé avec une raisin
qui qui nous montre une résilience
incroyable
donc je suis maintenant convaincu que
que la victoire
sera pour les ukrainiens et avec notre
avec notre appui est-ce que vous avez
l'impression on a parlé et on en avait
parlé vous et moi de cette crainte qui
avait les Ukrainiens qu'on les oublie
que cette guerre là tombe dans l'oubli
que la communauté internationale
cesse de se préoccuper de ce qui se
passait sur le terrain aujourd'hui un an
plus tard est-ce qu'on a l'impression
qu'ils c'est aussi présent que la
présence internationale est toujours là
aussi forte
internationale est plus grande
aujourd'hui que que qu'on était
juste la semaine dernière
tous les jours il y a des leaders des
pays à partner du grain qui sont qui qui
sont ici à Kiev chaque jour il y a des
nouvelles engagements de la part de leur
de leurs partenaires y compris le Canada
nous venons de voir
l'annonce du Premier ministre que le
Canada fournira
des chars des munitions des cartouches
notre véhicule blindé il y a plus de
sanctions que nous imposerons donc les
Ukrainiens me disent tous les jours
et que notre présence est très important
et c'est notre présence qui leur donne
le l'espoir de continuer
il y a des il y a des analystes du
conflit qui regardent ça à distance et
qui se disent peut-être que la solution
elle doit passer par une négociation
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
les Ukrainiens ont passé plusieurs
années en négociation avec les Russes
après après 2015
ils savent très très bien que les Russes
ne négocient pas de bonnes avec un bon
froid pas du tout donc ça c'est pourquoi
les les
Ukrainiens sont déterminés que cette
guerre sera terminée d'une façon
militaire combien de temps est-ce qu'ils
peuvent encore tenir le coup les
Ukrainiens un an plus tard et on sent on
sent le
stress que s'impose sur les soldats sur
le terrain on croyait que l'hiver allait
donner un avantage aux soldats ukrainien
les rues sont quand même réussi à
maintenir certaines positions combien de
temps ils peuvent maintenir le coup
d'après vous l'année passée c'est une
année à plein de surprises le plus grand
surprise pour moi c'est la ténacité la
résilience la détermination des
Ukrainiens donc
je ne vais je ne ferais pas de des
prognos des
même estimé parce que vraiment pour les
Ukrainiens c'est leur existence c'est
une bataille existentiaire pour pour eux
et ils vont continuer
aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra
vous êtes ambassadrice du Canada Kiev en
Ukraine merci infiniment d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin merci Daniel